seemingly overnight the city of Hong
Kong went from being a beacon of Liberty
to a communist controlled police state
the Chinese Communist Party is imposing
so-called national security laws now on
Hong Kong that will effectively end the
city's 23 years of self-rule now
yesterday Secretary of State Mike Pompeo
released a jaw-dropping statement
declaring the United States can no
longer recognize Hong Kong as autonomous
from China adding while the United
States once hoped that free and
prosperous Hong Kong would provide a
model for authoritarian China it's now
clear that China is modeling Hong Kong
after itself joining us now the
Secretary of State Mike Pompeo mr.
secretary thank you for joining us
tonight
your statement seemed to signal the
beginning of a new era in us-china
relations and can you tell us tonight
without getting ahead of the president
that this is a serious turn away for our
from our engagement with China to a much
tougher approach to what they've done to
Hong Kong Laura it's great to be with
you the statement that I made yesterday
was something that the President had
been working on the Chinese Communist
party's crushing what was so special
about Hong Kong what made it different
from the rest of China well the
financial center that was there all of
those things are now tragically going to
be gone and as a result of that the
president no longer believes that it's
justified to treat Hong Kong differently
than we treat the rest of what takes
place under the tyranny of the Chinese
Communist Party so I think you'll see in
the coming days president make a series
of announcements with respect to this
that recognizes the threat to the United
States of America the American people's
security as a emanates from this
tyrannical regime inside of China make
no mistake about a president Trump is
the first president and this isn't
political President Bush President Obama
they all refused to recognize the threat
that the Chinese Communist Party
presented to the United States of
America they were stealing intellectual
property from us they were moving in the
South China Sea all the things that that
you know and presidents before just
throw the head they wouldn't do it
Biden's foreign policy advisor you won't
be surprised to hear this mr. secretary
has
unkind things to say about your
administration's dealings with China
saying President Trump has talked tough
on China as you just did but he failed
to make any meaningful stand against the
Chinese government and that's why it's
no surprise China's leaders hope for
four more years a president Trump
mr. secretary Biden himself then said
that you've all been weak on China
because the president has an affinity
for authoritarians noting that he's
praised president G your response to the
Biden camp tonight nonsense it sounds
like they're pretty worried about having
to defend eight years of what Barack
Obama failed to do to contain the threat
to America from the Chinese Communist
Party do you think China would prefer
all things considered Biden to win in
November I can tell you this the
president's going to make sure that we
protect the American people from the
threats that the Chinese Communist Party
presents to the United States I just saw
none of that during the obama-biden
years the New York Times said today that
the u.s. is planning to expel Chinese
grad students with ties to China's
military schools and saying that you
know the universities are weary of a
possible new Red Scare that targets
students of a specific national
background that could contribute to
anti-asian racism mr. secretary number
one are you worried about anti Chinese
racism and number two aren't all Chinese
nationals who come here aren't they all
vetted in some way shape or form by the
CCP so why not Expo expel all of them at
least temporarily until China you know
somehow changes its tune Laura I'm not
surprised to hear that from the New York
Times frankly we're taking seriously the
threat that students that come here who
have connections deeply to the Chinese
state they they shouldn't be here in our
school spying as a former CI director I
take seriously the threat of espionage
inside of our country we know we have
this challenged president Trump I'm
confident is going to take that out I
don't want to get in front of what he's
going to say tomorrow but the American
people should know that the Chinese
Communist Party has worked to have
enormous influence here in the United
States this isn't this isn't a Red Scare
this isn't racist Chinese people are
great people this is like the days of
the Soviet Union this is a communist
tyrannical regime
that poses real risks to the United
States and we have an obligation a duty
to make sure the students who are coming
here to study to take the benefits of
coming to America to learn and to
benefit from what we can provide to them
aren't acting on behalf of the Chinese
Communist Party well I just don't see
how you prevent prevent anyone coming in
here from China under the current
circumstances from not being connected
to the Chinese government but I'll move
on the firing of the department
inspector general this was speaker
Pelosi's reaction watch when they come
close to looking at behavior that that
might cause them some unease they fire
them and a secretary Pompeo said he
should have fired him a long time ago
because he wasn't acting in the manner
in which we wanted him to act what does
that mean a turn a blind eye oh I to
wrongdoing what is it that they are
afraid of secretary Pompeo was the IG
fired for investigating you your
dealings with staff running errands the
Saudi arms deal can you go into any
detail about why he was let go tonight I
can and I said it earlier I regret that
I didn't recommend to the president
earlier that he'd be terminate he was
acting way that was deeply inconsistent
with what the State Department was
trying to do he his office was leaking
information we tried to get him to be
part of a team that was going to help
protect his own officers from Kovan 19
he refused to be an active participant
he was investigating policies he simply
didn't like that's not the role of an
inspector general this didn't have
anything to do with retaliation this was
about an IG those attempting to
undermine the mission of the United
States Department of State that's
unacceptable and so I recommended the
president he terminate Steve linic and
secretary finally the first terror
attack on American soil after 9/11
planned abroad took place in Pensacola
with three of our sailors being killed
by a Saudi nationals linked to al Qaeda
last December why are any Saudis
training with our troops who have any
ties to any organization or tear
related after what happened on 9/11 I
just don't understand why any of them
are here training on American soil given
the fact that apparently they can just
often end up killing American sailors so
I'll leave the details of the program to
the Department of Defense your viewers
should know the United States takes
seriously anytime we have anyone coming
in to train alongside our soldiers here
in the United States from whatever
country they're coming in from we have a
responsibility to our best to vet them
clearly this fellow got in and was a bad
actor and caused enormous harm and
paying to the United States of America I
know the department defense is reviewing
that process trying to make sure we get
it right we do conduct important
training programs so that young American
kids don't have to fly all the airplanes
all across the world to keep America
safe we want to sell American armaments
we want to train foreign military actors
to operate that equipment so that we
don't have to put young American lives
at risk I know that's why those training
programs exist we have to execute them
in a way that doesn't present the very
risk that you identified their lure was
that an Intel failure the fact that we
didn't pick up the the chatter that he
was involved with on planning a special
operation I don't know the details but
clearly as its unfolded as the FBI has
done its work they've concluded that he
was a member of al-qaeda and we didn't
identify that in a timely fashion
secretary Pompeo thank you so much for
joining us tonight we look forward to
seeing the president's remarks I believe
tomorrow on the next move with China
thanks so much sir thank you Laura have
a good evening